got to fulfill a childhood dream and
playing a superhero in a you know
leather leather suit and shoot laser
beams out of my eyes this was the
project that sort of catapulted me into
people knowing who the hell I was The
Notebook the movie that no one thought
would become what it's become an
opportunity for me to be in a full body
cast evidently
hairspray was a blast Maybe the most fun
I've ever had on a movie I just remember
that smile was plastered on my face even
when we weren't filming it was just so
much fun hairspray and Enchanted were
shot in the same year so it was a lot of
singing and dancing that year going back
to the notebook I remember running into
Ryan and Rachel Ryan goes did I see you
on top of a bus in a print suit in
Tights uh in Times Square I said yes sir
that was me